je ne crois pas que lorsque les
personnes sont attaquées de la sorte
elles ressentent un mélange elles sont
simplement attaqué et leurs vies sont
brisées
mais je croyais que vous étiez ministre
les années précédentes et j'ai dû me
tromper car non seulement vous semblez
découvrir les faits mais vous reprenez
aujourd'hui une partie des réponses et
des propositions pardon que nous avions
formulées pourtant elles ont été
rejetées elles ont été rejeté avec
mépris saoulé quinquennat hollande et
macro récemment les peines planchers
pour ceux qui attaquent nos forces de
l'ordre rejeter les places de prison
supplémentaires nous attendons encore
l'expulsion des étrangers qui
représentent une menace rejeté aussi
vous citer tout à l'heure des chiffres
mais ces chiffres sont largement
insuffisants et les propositions que
nous avions faites vous les avez tous
méprisé aujourd'hui c'est en moyenne 120
attaques à l'armé blanche selon
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
observatoire qui a malheureusement été
supprimés alors que ces attaques étaient
souvent à l'époque liées au terrorisme
islamique elles sont aujourd'hui
reléguées à la rubrique faits divers et
vous prononcez toujours les mêmes mots
vous nous dites que nous mélangeons où
vous dites que ce sont des risques des
déséquilibres et des actes isolés ce qui
est un déni de la réalité
vous considérez souvent nos questions
comme illégitimes ou les qualifier même
de nauséabonde et nous ferions de la
récupération politique
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
dire que les tweets ne remplace pas
l'action et combien de vies blessés
perdu ou abîmés sont aujourd'hui perdus
ou abîmés parce que vous n'avez pas
repris nos propositions
[Musique]